first our top story tonight a new batch
of Twitter files have officially now
been released only moments ago
journalist Barry Weiss published the
latest details on covering the social
media Giants censorship campaign and
what we're learning tonight is downright
appalling newly Unearthed documents now
prove that left-wing Twitter employees
built blacklists of accounts that they
didn't like and would quote prevent
disfavored tweets from trending and
actively limit the visibility of entire
accounts or even trending topics all in
secret without informing anybody on
Twitter for example a prominent doctor
from Stamford was secretly placed on the
trends Blacklist after he argued that
covet lockdowns would harm children and
meanwhile our very own tampon Gino he
was put on a search Blacklist limiting
who could search for his profile or
tweets he will join us and respond in
just a minute now Twitter also blocked
turning points uh founder Charlie Kirk's
tweets from being Amplified apparently
Twitter handled up to 200 of these
censorship cases each and every day but
remember as Weiss points out Twitter
repeatedly denied the use of Shadow
Banning Twitter was lying they lied over
and over again I had interviewed at one
point Jack Dorsey he told me
specifically no we don't Shadow ban now
we're also learning tonight that Twitter
formed a secret group that featured the
company's highest ranking Executives
that would make decisions in private
without much of a paper trail to censor
or ban high-profile conservative
accounts like for example a popular
account called Libs of tick tock which
was suspended six times in 2022 even
though the account did not even violate
Twitter's hateful conduct policy at the
same time the women who runs lives of
tick tock was doxed uh on Twitter in
other words they give out the address of
the person according to Weiss a tweet
with her home address received more than
ten thousand likes and yet Twitter
refused to take down that Tweet now
clearly what Elon Musk said over the
weekend was absolutely correct Twitter
was an arm of the democratic party and a
malicious arm take a look
clearly if if Twitter is doing one
team's bidding for an election shutting
down dissenting voices
on a pivotal election
that is the very definition of lecture
interference and what the hell else
would you of course it's like yes
um you know that frankly Twitter was
acting like an arm of the Democratic
National Committee it was absurd
an arm of the Democratic National
Committee shutting down dissenting
voices is by its very definition and
appearance now it's not only Twitter
almost every big tech company acted as
an arm of the democratic party and
interfered in our elections and tonight
I call on all of them Apple Google
Facebook all of you follow Elon Musk
lead you need to be transparent and by
the way will the media mob finally take
note don't hold your breath because as
Elon Musk suggested on Saturday many in
the media mob they are totally
completely compromised my words his word
complicit take a listen well I think
those people should be looking in the
mirror and wondering why they were
deceptive why did they deceive the
American public and and instead of
trying to redirect blame to Matthew they
need to be accepting some responsibility
themselves for not being truthful to the
American public not being truthful to
the American public now obviously big
Tech and big media they have been acting
as an arm of the democratic party for
quite some time that's not news to this
audience but we may never know the full
extent of their efforts now because get
this now Elon Musk is suggesting that
some files may have been deleted or
removed now this came out after musk
discovered that the controversial ex-fbi
russiagate lawyer James Baker was
personally reviewing and approving the
initial batch of Twitter files that were
put out by Matt taibi and Baker was
still serving as a top lawyer for
Twitter until musk fired him earlier
this week this is a huge story now
instead of voicing concern about
Twitter's collusion with the DNC and
potentially the federal government many
so-called journalists are now more
worried that musk installed beds at
Twitter's headquarters in case employees
were tired working a lot of overtime so
they'd have a place to get a few hours
asleep San Francisco what's their
reaction to being nice to your employees
oh let's open up an investigation on
Elon Musk now that prompted this
response from Elon Musk so the city of
San Francisco attacks companies
providing beds for tired employees
instead of making sure kids are safe
from fentanyl where are your priorities
mayor London breed but the madness
doesn't stop there now the compromise
congenital liar Adam Schiff he's so
deeply troubled by Elon Musk and his
pushed for free speech that he's now
just flat out lying about hate speech on
the platform citing zero evidence at all
whatsoever Schiff tweeted earlier today
quote against slurs against black people
have tripled on Elon musk's Twitter and
claimed that slurs against women are on
the rise too musk immediately poured
cold water on those claims replying
quote false hate speech impressions are
actually down by a third for Twitter Now
versus prior to the acquisition
meanwhile the White House Press
Secretary asked about the Twitter files
and the Democratic push for censorship
earlier today by our own peter Ducey all
she wanted to do was uh not answer the
question and say bye bye
you've said a few times that you really
can't talk about Communications between
the Biden campaign and Twitter
is telling you that that's off limits I
I've already had that conversation with
you with your colleague I believe
yesterday
I've already addressed this multiple
times this week so I don't have anything
more to add again I've we've we've we've
litigated this all week don't have
anything to add so I'm going to the back
I'm going to the back I'm going to bed
go ahead
all right so let me get this straight so
we know now according to Elon Musk that
the Democratic party the FBI also
involved with weekly meetings warning
Twitter that there may be false
information about Hunter Biden coming
out you got to be on the lookout for
this before the election meanwhile they
had Hunter Biden's laptop a full 11
months uh before the 2020 2020
presidential election uh then Elon Musk
says yes suppressing information is by
definition election interference uh but
the White House doesn't want to talk
about it because they benefited from it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else